This can really change anything,
because Sarah Wagenknecht steps out of the left
and founds a new party.
She has millions of clicks on YouTube,
is one of the best known politicians in Germany
and finds the left,
no longer makes a left-wing policy.
For the European election 2,024
they already want to compete with the new party.
And left-wing politics is mostly queer in Germany
friendly. But
how queer could wagenknechtspartei actually become?
An Analysis Wagenknecht
is generally not against gays
or lesbian apparently she is also not Persil
against transhumans,
this is how you could interpret it.
But she is against more identity politics.
Example theselbstbestimmungsgesetz.
That's supposed to make it easier,
his legally registered gender
to change Wagenknecht however
is against the law.
She means roughly,
that men thereby quickly become women
would make
and so for example in women's shelters
would pre-drink.
She finds the law bad.
By the way,
that women's houses themselves individually
decide on each individual person,
Whether this person is really accepted or not,
we have discussed this before here.
Nevertheless wagenknechtspartei
could do less identity politics,
but want to keep things like marriage for everyone.
Now it's out.